Melania Trump gave a speech denouncing
cyberbullying neatly afterwards
President Trump went on Twitter and
called her a loser immigrant at a White
Sox game this weekend did you see this a
Catholic nun threw out the first pitch
yeah
actually threw the ball at a priest who
was running after a batboy so saved him
a new study just came out found that
there are almost twice as many Canadians
living illegally in the United States
than Mexicans yeah
this explains why ice is now starting to
target polite people
I can add laughs later I really can i
cost about $8 a joke we should do that
sometime just add laughs sure yeah of
people from make the 50s laughing right
right
[Laughter]
take laughs from old I Love Lucy
episodes yeah nothing like dead people
laughing all right
a man has created ruin like this or not
can't tell with you guys eh
a man has created Amish uber which
drives Amish people where they need to
go using a horse and buggy yeah he said
the hard part is getting people to
download the app to their butter churn
you
you